I'm never surprised by controversies
that are whipped up in Washington right
that's that's par for the course but
I'll repeat what I said two days ago we
have a basic principle we do not leave
anybody wearing the American uniform
behind we had a prisoner of war whose
health had deteriorated and we were
deeply concerned about and we saw an
opportunity and we seized it and I make
no apologies for them we had discussed
with Congress the possibility that
something like this might occur but
because of the nature of the folks that
we were dealing with and the fragile
nature of these negotiations we felt it
was important to go ahead and do what we
did and we're now explaining to Congress
the details of how we move forward but
this basic principle that we don't leave
anybody behind and this basic
recognition that that often means
prisoner exchanges with enemies is not
unique to my administration it dates
back to the beginning of our Republic
and with respect to how we announced it
I think it was important for people to
understand that this is not some
abstraction this is not a political
football you have a couple of parents
whose kid to fight in a distant land who
they hadn't seen in five years and
weren't sure whether they'd ever see
again and as commander-in-chief of the
United States Armed Forces
I am responsible for those kids and I
get letters from parents who say if you
are in fact sending my child into war
make sure that that child is being taken
care of and I write too many letters to
folks who unfortunately don't see their
children
after fighting a war I make absolutely
no apologies for making sure that we get
back a young man to his parents and that
the American people understand that this
is somebody's child and that we don't
condition whether or not we make the
effort to try to get them back